from a manufacturing standpoint the way
we assemble this car the way we put it
together all of this is essentially very
different from another car
[Music]
the model s process stages it all starts
with raw material
we have coils of aluminum different
gauges different types of aluminum maybe
50 60 coils
[Music]
we start the process by uncoiling the
coils in a special machine we call
blanking machine that allows to flatten
the metal person and cut it into flat
pieces we call them blanks in addition
to traditional blanking tools we're
using laser
and then with these species we feed them
to the press lines these gigantic dyes
and the press lines essentially form
the panels you know boom
[Music]
we are getting all of the parts
necessary to make the body of the
vehicle out of those gigantic machines
and then all of these parts as they are
finished so to speak are brought to the
body shop
[Music]
the role of the body center is to take
all the stamping panels that we make and
we bring all that together in one
central location
and that's where we actually put the
model s together
we'll start we do an underbody which is
the main floor system of the car
and then from there we'll move to body
sides that's the internal reinforcement
as well as the outer skin
and inside the framing area we take the
body sides the underbody and the front
end of the car and we actually marriage
it all together
[Music]
one of the most unique things about this
body center is we actually have five
different overall joining methods for
the body shell we use adhesive
we use self-piercing rivets we have cold
metal transfer
conventional resistance welding as well
as a new delta spot welding system
when a body leaves the body center it's
actually a full completed body shell
ready to be prepped and painted
you have a gigantic robot that takes the
body and put into a conveyor it is
conveying to the paint shop
you have multiple pre-treatment primer
base coat clear coat
all of this is supplied with robots that
have a special ability to paint in a
very clean environment
you get a beautiful painted body that's
coming to general assembly where we have
these super elegant robots we call smart
cart where every car is essentially
moving through the factory by itself
it follows a magnetic strip and
essentially the car is being assembled
from inside out
[Music]
we're utilizing automation to the
fullest we have a variety of robots from
the the teenager ones to huge one that
are able to move the entire body
[Music]
itself one of the robot that i i'm
always very impressed to look at is the
one that puts the seats inside the model
s
and the same robot is able to change
tools go from a seat handling device to
putting the windshield
actually grab the windshield put some
glue around it and then put the winching
onto the car as well as do the rear
glass of the vehicle so talk about
versatility here
we have most everything we need right
here in house we do the majority of our
stamping panels ourselves
we have design engineers here at the
facility so we're very nimble and very
quick at what we do
currently it takes about three to five
days for modelers to go from raw
material all the way to being finished
on the bamboo line
it's magnificent it's like a piece of
art
we constantly try to improve process
efficiency we want to push the
boundaries of what can be done by robots
versus humans so it's a constant
evolution
this tesla factory is the future of the
usa and the world that's the way i see
it
[Music]
we are building the future here that's
how proud i feel about this
[Music]